tris les étrangers se les arrachent non
point les tartes belge mais les
[ __ ] vertes ce groupe au nom
curieux qui aiment tout à la fois le
rock la java la musette et le rail
leur musique métissée comme l'on dit
maintenant a même séduit madonna qui
leur a commandé une chanson les
[ __ ] vertes sont à paris à l'espace
cardin jusqu'à samedi avant de
participer au printemps de bourges
pascal deschamps et christian hottin
n'ont pas manqué le spectacle
l'accordéoniste vient du cirque things
are où le guitariste vient des saintes
maries de la mer
les autres viennent de partout ailleurs
les tapis viennent de barbès le chanteur
vient de la banlieue
la vraie et le nom les [ __ ] vertes
figurez-vous qu'il vient du jura non
c'est un espèce de hip hop rap sont de
la musette
ça se passait dans un bal du jura dans
un bal de bûcherons et c'est une insulte
au départ les my way lui casser la tête
nous ont traités de [ __ ] vertes
parti de rien il mélange tout tout ce
qu'ils aiment d'edith piaf au tam-tam
africains de boris vian au flamenco
ouais
le mélange ces français distille après
tout ils auront aussi chanter bien la
rumba et c'est ce mélange là qui a plu à
l'étranger
sans fin
l'un de leurs personnages boit pour
oublier qu'il vit le font la fête pour
oublier comme le dit le chanteur que si
l'enfer existe il est sur la terre il
suffit de regarder tous les jours les
actualités tu peux tu as du mal à
imaginer que quelque part ailleurs ça
peut être pire que ce qu'il ya sur terre
quoique là il fait beau il ya du soleil
on fait de la musique on apporte de la
joie mais non certains pays il ya du
soleil mais après il ya pas trop musique
et a pas trop le choc et ail et de la
torture il ya des choses et même le
diable serait pas capable de faire mieux
donc si le diable est quelque part il
est ici sur terre après l'allemagne
ils seront à londres qui les réclament à
cor et à cri
la preuve que si vous vous fait
méchamment traitée de négresse verte
dans un bal du jura ça peut vous mener
très loin